TO GET INSIDE EXPERIENCE IT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US. MY AND TOMORROW LIKE YOU
SAID IT'S GOING TO BE A IT'S
GOING IT'S GOING TO BE
ALRIGHT, COMEDIAN TOM PAPA IS
HEADLINING ENCORE THEATER AT
WYNN FOR THE FIRST TIME FRIDAY
NIGHT MERCEDES SPOKE WITH HIM
ABOUT THAT AND SO MUCH MORE.
SO EXCITED. PAPA IS JOINING
ME WELCOME BACK TO LAS VEGAS
ON COURT THEATER WHAT IS IT
LIKE AS FAR AS THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN A VEGAS CROWDS AND
SALT LAKE CITY CROWD WHICH I
KNOW YOU WERE JUST IN SALT
LAKE CITY.
WEEKEND. IT'S THE COOLEST PART
ABOUT VEGAS IS THAT YOU GET
EVERYBODY FROM ALL AROUND THE
COUNTRY INTO ONE SPOT YOU CAN
SEE WHY COMEDIANS DO THIS AT A
CERTAIN POINT THEY JUST STAY
IN VEGAS AND LET AUDIENCE HAS
COME TO YOU RATHER THAN RUN
ALL AROUND THE COUNTRY AND
HAVE TO GO SEE THEM.
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU WOULD
EVER CONSIDERED A LIKE A
PERMANENT VEGAS RESIDENCY
YEAR DOING THAT NIGHTLY.
YES A 100%. WELL I THINK
YOU MENTIONED WHICH I'M A BIG
FAN OF HIS IS YOUR PODCAST
BREAKING BREAD WITH THAT AND
YOU'VE GOT INTO BREAD BAKING
THING I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE
DID DURING THE PANDEMIC.
IS THIS SOMETHING THEY I'M
THINKING THIS IS A PERFECT
MARKETING OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU
AT YOUR SHOW AT THE WIN THIS
WEEKEND. WHY ARE YOU SO LITTLE
OF BREAD THAT YOU BAY.
I KNOW YOU KNOW IT'S SO
FUNNY I I WAS DOING AWAY
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC BECOME
WELL KNOWN FOR IT. BUT I DON'T
SELL IT. I DON'T HAVE ANY WAY
TO MONETIZE IT I FEEL LIKE I'M
BLOWING AN OPPORTUNITY WHAT
IT'S SO TO MAKE A ROLL INTO AN
FILLED WITH HE DIDN'T DO IT I
THINK THAT WE HAVE A CALLER
ID. 2 DAUGHTERS, HOW'S THAT
WORKING OUT FOR YOU.
IT'S THE BEST EVEN WHEN
THEY DON'T LIKE YOU IT'S THE
HAHA YOU LIKE THE COOL DAD. I
MEAN YOU GUYS LISTEN TO MUSIC
TOGETHER.
LIKE WHAT ARE THEY INTO
RIGHT NOW I KNOW YOU'RE BIG ON
TIKTOK DO THEY THINK IT'S COOL
THAT DADS VERIFIED ON NOW THAT
ACTUALLY.
MADE THEM A LITTLE ANGRY
STUFF LIKE THAT WAS OKAY, BUT
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY ACTUALLY
SAID AND TIKTOK IS TIKTOK IS
FOR US THAT'S NOT FOR YOU.
THIS LIKE THAT WAS THEIR OWN
CELEBRITIES AND STUFF AND NOW
THEY'RE VERY DISAPPOINTED YOU
GO I WAS WONDERING IF I COULD
DO A COUPLE QUICK.
QUESTION TO YOU SOME
RAPID-FIRE QUESTIONS ALRIGHT
THE ANSWER. BEST CONCERT
YOU'VE EVER SEEN IN YOUR LIFE.
BRUNO MARS IN LAS VEGAS. LAST
THING THAT YOU GOOGLED I WAS
FRANK HAS A PROBLEM THAT THE
KIND OF CAR YOU DRIVE. MUST
HAVE ITEM ON THE ROAD.
CHEEZ-ITS. HAVE YOU EVER
STOLEN ANYTHING. YES, BUT WHEN
I WAS LITTLE I I WOULD STEAL
GUM BUT THAT WASN'T MY FAULT
THAT CAME OUT WITH BUBBLY ON
THEM BUT DELICIOUS AND WE'VE
NEVER SEEN IT BEFORE WE HAD NO
MONEY AND THERE'S ONLY ONE WAY
TO GET IT AND LAST BUT NOT
LEAST WAS THE CELEBRITY YOU
GET MISTAKEN FOR IF I'M A
LITTLE CHUBBY JHANSI RILEY.
AND IF THE LIGHTER JOHN